hey everyone this is steve lanchot with
collider and i am thrilled to be with
the people behind bruiser here at the
toronto international film festival i
want to start with congrats on the movie
to all of you and congrats on being part
of this tremendous festival um it is
i love this place it is just such a
great celebration of movies i hate doing
the generic thing at the beginning but
because everyone watching will have not
seen the movie yet who wants to bite the
bullet and say the how they've been
describing the film to friends and
family the director of course
um the film is basically about a 14 year
old boy who comes back from boarding
school
and gets caught up in this conflict
basically between a
charismatic
loner
who he meets who lives on a houseboat
and his father um and it's about these
two men who have a past uh and who know
each other um kind of fighting um
in as as this kid kind of enters their
lives um and it's a
it's a movie um
kind of based in that in that world so
yeah
one one of the things i'm so curious um
obviously everyone reads in if you're an
actor you read a lot of scripts you hope
to get a role for each of you what was
it about the script that you most
resonated with that said oh my god i
really want this part
um monica i like that she's an empath
you get to see all sides of her
and unconditionally she loves these
three different men very differently
and
she has exactly or knows and understands
what each person needs and so it was
very fun to me to show their versatility
with each
actor that i would share the screen with
um
for me it was
the fact that uh darius is like you know
going through a lot and
a bunch of emotions like in every
given moment
so that to me felt like really good to
try to portray and bring his truth out
and for me it was
holistically
the duality between the two fathers
and the polarities
and having the opportunity to be a part
of something that showcased that
and the fact that it's about
a father's love for his son
two fathers love for their son
uh that's reflective of my life because
you know my f my son was just born a
year ago so this is like a
a birthday present to him for me so
it's all encompassing one of the things
that struck me was that oh and i don't
like to do spoilers or get specific but
the opening shot of the movie has three
people in the grass and i'm just curious
how did you decide that that's how you
wanted to open the movie
for me it was always like a kind of
thematic thing i knew i wanted an image
that was like quick and and and striking
that you could kind of be like okay this
is the movie it's these three men um
or com someone becoming a man in a
certain way um
lying there um kind of i guess
could be dead or you know it's like the
there's a lot of different kind of
things you could take from it um but i
wanted like a striking image um that
kind of sets the tone for the movie and
and to show the audience so this is
probably what they're gonna see for the
rest of the time in terms of the themes
in terms of the visual imagery of what's
going to come next
i have a follow-up for you another
aesthetic choice that you made with the
film was shooting at 4-3 and i'm curious
if your producers or the people
financing it at any point said to you i
don't know about this like was that
actually a battle it was not a battle it
was not i was very very clear about it
from the beginning i had done a short
film um also titled bruiser um which was
in the same aspect ratio in the same
format um so they they knew what i
wanted and and they knew that i was
important to kind of
creating the the kind of
claustrophobia of these as these two men
as they their grip on their on well one
biological father one stepfather grip on
their son you know loosens or and and um
you know they feel more and more trapped
and caged and so i it was never really
uh necessarily a battle it's kind of we
always knew it needed to happen for the
movie to kind of feel
the way you know we wanted it to
for the cast
i'm imagining when you're reading the
script and you're looking at the
shooting schedule there's a day or two
on the shoot that you have circled
meaning like you know it might be a
tough day you know it might be emotional
it might pull something out of you for
each of you what was the day on the and
also for directing what was the day on
the shoot that you're like this is going
to be a tough day
um
i think mine was
my scene with
my mother
um
it was very intense and kind of out of
i'm not gonna say out of my character
but
it was a place that i had to go
that i don't usually visit um trying to
keep it vague here um but they they know
what i'm talking about and soon audience
will know what i'm talking about but it
was a very like
stuffy
you know intense moment that i knew that
i would have to perform
for me i'll say the the diner scene
where you come in
that's me was a lot of dialogue and a
lot of beats and as an actor i want to
make sure that i'm covering every beat
but and i was very terrified of that
scene but when we got there the way that
we flowed i was very appreciative of
just letting go and just
feeling the rhythm of the scene
so yeah
uh and for me man i i just never really
uh associated like that i just i'm just
present and it's peaceful i'm chilling
always
[Laughter]
i wish i wish i could be like that but
no i i uh for me it was then the ending
when i we had two days to shoot the
ending i'm not going to say what happens
but um
it was
you know it was a challenge it was cold
it was
it was uh it had a lot to do little time
and it was like this big sequence and i
very was was very terrified but we got
it done so one of the things uh the film
when i was watching it it felt like i
was watching real people talk about real
things like very natural dialogue um was
was anything tweaked when you started
doing i don't know if you did any
rehearsals or if you did any table reads
or how did you make it so it felt as
organic as it could be while you're
delivering you know what i mean yeah no
no totally uh
yeah you're right it was a lot i think a
lot of the dialogue was especially true
travante definitely like took my
dialogue
he basically took my dialogue and
interpreted it and put it through his
own mouth and it was like would sound
completely and feel completely different
and and that
in you know itself created i think
something very authentic and i mean all
of you guys i mean some like maybe not
to the degree that travante did but you
know jalen would say it would be like i
don't know if i'd say this and i'd i'm
kind of one of those directors that's
like great say it how you would say it
um
and i like to
make sure that you know if if they if
they feel comfortable saying stuff in
the way they would do it or the way that
they think their character should i'm
like yeah go ahead i'm not very precious
about this script and i think it helps
getting some more naturalistic kind of
um dialogue and performances so
so what there's this is not a spoiler
but part of the movie takes place on a
ferris wheel which is not an easy place
to film because it's moving around and
it's very tall so i'm just curious if
you could talk a little bit about
filming on the ferris wheel and what it
was like trying to get the shots that
you wanted because it's not you can't
have a crane following that thing that
is not you know
no that's that's a good question yeah um
we
it was tough i knew i wanted to be on
the ferris wheel with them and i knew it
was really important um basically what
we did was just kind of like
rigged a little camera you know on front
of it and then it would kind of go
around with them and keep us in that
place um
but it was a tough shot um just because
i was like oh i want to like stay with
them and just go around and around and
around
um
and so yeah it ended up just being we we
would we just rigged to the front of it
and then and then
put on a really wide angle lens so we
could see as much as possible and then i
just let them do their thing you know
i'm curious for you guys uh when you're
filming the ferris wheel stuff is it one
of these things where like you you want
to get through the scene as quick as you
can because you're like i don't want to
keep going on the ferris wheel are you
sort of like this is a great night i
want to keep going absolutely not i was
having the best time on there yeah like
it was not even
it was cold very cold but i was having a
lot of fun i told him like before the
night was over i was like i'm riding one
of these rides
so luckily i did
yeah ditto man it was it was uh
it was so beautiful like some of the
times like
the money would like hit my mouth it was
just such a beautiful like it was just a
beautiful moment and it was it was cool
it was really cool
i'm always curious about how films
change in the editing room the editing
process specifically because that's
where everything comes together so i'm
curious what did you learn from any
friends and family screenings that
impacted the finished film and when did
you three of you actually see it at what
point in the edit
so in terms of the edit i
you know it was very it was very
interesting process i mean it's my first
film but i it was a lot of
basically i shot very specifically we
didn't have much time we didn't have
much money so
the things i shot it was very like
planned out and you know we did end up
rearranging a lot of stuff but a lot of
it stayed how it was written and how i
wanted to be um
after the first kind of test screenings
i think the major thing was just pacing
stuff i think we like you know we made
it sped it up a little bit you know not
too much but like um the main thing was
just streamlining some things um
and some stuff at the beginning and some
stuff towards the end um and so there
but there were no like major kind of
like
changes in terms of like see scenes or
anything like that um i think it was
just kind of
we had a plan and we sucked to it and
then we tweaked small things you know
um
but yeah
when did you guys see it
um about the same time they'll be
they these these two haven't seen it yet
yeah oh so you're seeing the premiere
yep
are you scared or are you sort of like
he's gonna be excited i'm excited
i'm very excited did you do this so you
did it on purpose you wanted to wait or
or they didn't well well the movie like
hasn't
i finished it like a week ago
you know it's one of those it's one of
those and it's like i'm i don't i'm like
might as well just see it when we screen
it in the theater with the sound because
it's it literally just the sound was
finished like
last week you know
i mean not to bring in another thing but
like a lot of things uh like that
stranger things recent season like the
duffers told me they finished it like
the day it came out literally they were
uploading a tweak to like the netflix
server like right
yeah you know this is obviously not a
vfx movie but you get what i mean i mean
but that's also the benefit of like
today and making films today
like making music today you can like
edit it right then and you know you
always you know how artists are too
always tweaking as long as you give them
time they can always you know well a lot
of people talk about the fact that like
you literally have to have it pulled
away from you yeah because like you'll
keep yeah i was going to say it's like
you kind of have to decide when when
you're going to stop doing your tweaks
which is i had like it was good because
i was like oh use the festival to kind
of this festival to be like okay it's
happening now i have to stop making
tweets you know
completely for all four of you what are
you most excited for audiences to see
with this movie
i mean i'll start um
i think miles is really one of the
is a really
interesting really unique very
understood very intelligent very
beautiful voice
that
i've been yearning for like i i i aspire
to direct so i've been writing and
getting myself in that way because
that's the energy that i want to convey
so
to have the opportunity to
be a part of it
as well as obviously be able to see it
i've seen it a couple times you know and
just to
know somebody like that it's really cool
because i think he's got a lot of
wonderful wonderful pieces to share with
the world for sure
thank you
appreciate that
miles has taken something you know
social media
um world star has desensitized people to
you know
to human beings and i i love that he has
brought humanity to these three black
men and people get to see how tender
they are and they get to see that people
aren't just violent it comes from
something you know so
i'm very excited to be a part of this
and this is just the beginning of
someone who's very young and well beyond
their their years so i feel like i'm a
part of something he's 55. he's 15
that's young spirit and spirit and
spirit i've had a lot of work done oh my
god
but yeah
so much ahead of you at 55.
well
you know i'm not as wise as him
but um
but i think that
um a lot of you know the world is black
and white right now you know like what's
good and what's bad and at first glance
like when i was just chopping it up with
um
my mom like before even
because my mom like before y'all i'm i'm
just telling y'all no she do not look at
the script so
she'd be like she'd be like oh for real
so i was chopping it up with her about
the scripts
and at first she was like what like she
was going on the roller coaster but
hasn't even seen any i'm just reading
the lines but she was just like
so who's like so who's crooked like
who's the bad person
but that to me it's like
there's no bad or good
it's just emotions
that drive you to do certain things but
from the blind eye you'll see oh he's
the villain and he's the hero but
nobody's the villain or the hero so i
feel like
um when you see this you'll you'll
definitely see a lot of those tidbits
where you're like confused on what's bad
and what's good what's good what's
um what's right
but at the end of the day like you said
human humanity everybody's human and
they make choices so
just opening everyone's eyes to that
when they see it that boy wise yeah
right wise
i love that
um for me it's very simple it's
so for people to see these performances
i think i think the dedication and the
talent of this cast i've been so lucky
um
all of them are just bringing these
characters to life in such incredible
ways and i'm excited for audience to see
black characters that are
you know have morals that are what jalen
just said that less so like
stalk good bad characters and people
that feel real and like have
have real
[Music]
dru like goals and and drives um
and do things that are wrong and make
bad choices um and yeah i just i'm
excited for people to see these kind of
characters that i've
written over the past six years and
fallen in love with and and are and are
really excited that they've been brought
to life in such an incredible way so
yeah on that note i'm just gonna say
thank you so much for coming into our
studio today i really do hope this is a
huge hit for you guys i hope a ton of
people watch it and i wish you nothing
but the best of the festival thank you
thank you thank you so much
you